welcome to this video playing freedom
master funny bird denmark yes it's
denmark great i guess one right ok so
let's see should I play and that's
actually this line I wanted to wanted to
show you the show you show this anyway
it's a quite interesting way to sidestep
theory leads to a rather jerk off to a
playable position for white it's not not
anything special that you get a good
development and I think this is actually
better than let's say the London system
in terms of still playing for for
something but yeah maybe like be three I
didn't really pay attention to 96 and
this is actually quite good now
attending you fire but ok maybe I need
to be M yeah BM liberal with my
membership pair and just take this this
night so that he cannot play you five
for me
you're fine i just take it ok so this
threatening note nite xt4 sometimes
there are such moves
so while night c5 was 95 an idea
actually yeah well maybe a funny move
now let's just jump back the bishop is
it's not bad on f3 at all Bishop c6 I
have night a 5k a c6 yeah but this looks
comfortable like this position so a good
solid position where black is suffering
a bit with this Bishop only 7 which
doesn't really have a good good post
Bishop g5 visit the intention is for
Queen d2 maybe Bishop 86 and put some
pressure on when he's happened so he
cannot easily player let's say queen
move now he's obviously so annoyed with
though this u7 pressure the tea offers
this trade okay okay let's let's make
sure that that's never push a default
let's say our Queen d2 Bishop g4 so how
to continue Queen d2 to h6 this is
sometimes a good idea then rookie 50
maybe weekly five-hour wait will rookie
5 he can maybe play c5
hmm that's not the end of the world wait
wait wait c5 was just blundering the
exchange nonsense that's there's still
this nice bishop look you want
oh that's do it
attacking on e 7 and covering c 5 so
that tis see five movies are the two
harder to realize interesting going to
be some okay but this is good anyway
needs to play 697 maybe so probably I
need to make some room for the rook h4
h5 yeah
yeah it's a slide it's a slight pressure
but I think 97 and then c5 still should
be rather rather solid and simply okay
ok let's say let's take it a night
reform didn't really think about that
move so I right side said it's good
interesting and okay
okay that's let's reach out the Queen
down teck teck the night
all right this is risky but want to want
to increase the pressure with h5 maybe
it's just weakening for myself but so to
make some progress you sometimes need to
to risk something
the Sun Queen c7 g3 this looks like this
maybe some tactical ideas ok like this
if he takes c4 night moves look aged
five wins the Queen this kind of ideas
wow what the position ok I can go here
and take only six night moves I could
have taken on f6 but he's got g5
hmm where where where where where now to
Joe this is a temple or a big temple
I hope this is working it looks it looks
complicated yeah this wasn't so greater
probably the dipole check
check
time warning
we have six check check check check Wow
no idea what's going on this is a draw
now yeah probably I don't see how to get
out of this yeah it's the wrong yeah
good no idea rookie three what a shocker
yeah I could just take the Queen that
can just take the Queen no this is sick
look III I you didn't have I'm not sure
why the times not displayed I had this
before this is quite annoying to not see
the time okay yeah well very very
complicated stuff d 3 year what would
would win for black yeah and that's that
here I lost I lost the threat him yeah
black is better he already am this
wasn't this really wasn't working f6 was
strong oh no it wasn't strong I need to
play g5 I need to play g5 jack okay
yeah just this is good hmm yeah it was
very complicated with very little time
on the clock but an interesting metal
thanks for watching